i'm going  with the milwaukee books  no okay there could not be anything on  there yeah  hey ernie stop it's coming down honey  he's coming back  missed it earlier remember he's the only  one that didn't get it  steve abort abort fiorillo stop  hit the button fiorello it's a  malfunction  [Music]  hey they'll be stopped they'll be  dancing on the mean streets  yes they will i like milwaukee too i've  never had  balls drop on my head before  that's how you judge you hey andrew  brian posada  i love you judge judy thanks for talking  me on the phone one day  all right we'll take a break come back a  little bit more here on  inside the nba in just a second taking  these chuck bucks to magic city tonight